>> Hi, I'm Joe Gregorio and I work for Google
in
developer relations and today we're gonna
talk about
installing a Google App Engine application
into a
Google Apps domain.
You may wanna do this so your users have a
more uniform
experience with the application, as it'll
now show up in a
sub domain of your domain, and the user authentication
can
also use the single sign-on mechanism that
you use for the
rest of the Google Apps domain.
For example, I have this very simple App engine
application.
It's the simple "Hello world!" That ships
with Google App
engine.
So, it currently runs on appspot.com.
I also own the domain bitworking.info, which
is a Google
Apps domain.
Now, I'd like to install that "Hello world!"
application into
my domain.
So, the first thing we need to do is upload
my application.
And as you can see, I've already done that
and it's working
on the Appspot domain.
Now, I go to the application dashboard for
the Google App
engine.
I go down to versions and here I've only got
the first
version, version number one, and down here
it says domain
setup.
Want to host your application on another domain?
Yes, I do.
So, we will click "Add."
That is bitworking.info where I want to Add
that.
I click "Add."
Now, there are terms and conditions I need
to agree to.
You will need to read this carefully.
I accept those conditions and I will now Activate
the
service.
And that's it.
I'm done.
So, now if I go back to my domain, and refresh,
you'll now see
that jcgregorio-test, my simple "Hello world!"
Application is now available, and it's available
at this
domain.
So, now I can go in and add a new URL for
it, and I can
say -- I can add in, hello.
So, now that application will now be available
at
hello.bitworking.info.
I press "Add."
My site is updated and now it should be available.
So, let's try that.
hello.bitworking.info.
And there's my "Hello world!" application.
So, that shows you how to install that application
into the
domain.
We haven't available shown off any of the
authentication
options. So, in order to do that, let's go
back to our new
template project and add in one more thing
to it.
So, you can see here we're going to require
login to our
"Hello world!"
Once we do that, we're going to need to create
a new
application ID.
So, domain App testing, that's available.
And now when I create it I do wanna choose
a different style
of authentication.
You want to restrict logins to bitworking.info
domain.
Now, our domain has been created.
We now go through the same exact steps, as
we did before to
add this application into the bitworking info
domain.
Now, we have to, again, accept the service
agreement and there
we go.
It's been installed.
You add a new sub domain, and now the application
should be
available at that sub domain.
Now, when I go to access the Hello secure
application, I'm
redirected to the login for the bitworking.info
domain.
Once we log into the domain, now the application
is
available.
And that's it.
That's all it takes to add in an application
into your
domain.
Thanks, and have fun.